It’s a cold morning
in 15th century France,
and you're off to the barber
for a shave and a haircut.
You hear the familiar sound
of singing inside
and eye a bowl of blood in the window.
Both chairs are taken.
You grab a cup of ale and examine
the array of teeth strung from the walls.
Suddenly, a scream.
The barber’s apprentice wipes pus
from the boil he’s just lanced.
By the other chair,
the barber fixes a pair of pliers
over a blackened, rotting tooth.
For centuries, barbers in western and
northern Europe didn’t just cut hair,
they also performed a range of surgeries;
from tooth extraction to stitches,
and even amputation.
There were two main factors that led
to barbers filling this position.
Before this, these surgical procedures
were mostly performed by monks.
The clergymen were required
by the Catholic Church
to sport a very specific haircut,
called tonsures,
and to remove all facial hair,
so the monasteries generally
had at least one barber.
Given their proximity and ability
to work with sharp blades,
these barbers often assisted in surgeries.
And in 1215, the church issued an edict
banning monks from any act
that purposefully spilled blood.
At the same time,
universities with medical schools
were opening across Europe.
However, these doctors saw themselves
as academic scholars
who would never dirty their hands
by touching blood or wielding knives.
Medicine and surgery became two separate,
yet complementary, disciplines—
like geometry and carpentry.
So operations were left in the hands
and shears of barber-surgeons.
Rather than studying anatomy in textbooks,
barber-surgeons trained
through extended apprenticeships.
They often combined knowledge
of anatomy with astrology,
taking both the patient’s symptoms
and corresponding astrological events—
such as lunar phases—
into account when deciding on treatment.
Like many people of the time,
they regarded the position of the sun,
moon, and stars to be highly significant.
They also memorized poems to commit
information to memory—
such as one identifying where on the body
bloodletting should be performed.
For headaches, the temples;
for liver problems,
the little finger on the right hand;
and for hemorrhoids,
the back of the legs.
Barber-surgeons certainly kept busy.
From around 1300 CE,
unpredictable weather
across the North Atlantic
caused by what is now called
the Little Ice Age,
led to regular famines.
People often had to choose
between starvation
or eating rye flour that was contaminated
with the fungus ergot.
This led to widespread illnesses,
which in extreme cases caused gangrene,
or the rotting of body tissue.
When gangrene set in,
the only hope of saving a patient
was through amputation.
Barbers would saw off infected limbs,
covering the stumps with cow or pig
bladders while they healed.
And their work wasn’t limited
to just shops and monasteries.
Armies needed both hairdressing
and wound care,
and barber-surgeons accompanied them
on campaigns near and far.
Through the centuries, barber-surgeons
contributed important knowledge
to the medical establishment.
One of the most famous, Ambroise Paré,
blurred the lines
between doctor and barber-surgeon
by publishing medical textbooks
and teaching at France’s
first surgical college.
In the 16th century,
he gained renown as a military surgeon,
in part for advocating against the
painful and medically useless practice
of pouring boiling oil
into gunshot wounds.
Instead, he applied an antiseptic salve
of egg yolks, rosewater, and turpentine,
which soon became standard treatment
on battlefields across Europe.
By the 18th century, medical knowledge
started advancing rapidly.
New surgical techniques emerged
for closing wounds,
controlling blood loss,
and performing complex procedures,
like removing cancerous tissue.
Surgery became more specialized—
and under pressure
from the medical establishment—
barbers and surgeons soon split
into clear-cut occupations.
Surgeons and dentists entered the ranks
of university-trained
medical practitioners,
while barbers remained craftsmen
who learned their trade
through apprenticeships.
However, the legacy of the barber-surgeon
can still be seen today,
perhaps most prominently in the
red and white stripes on the barber pole—
which, according to legend,
represent blood and the bandages used
by their pre-modern counterparts.